intermittent fasting we all know people
fast for weight loss but researchers are
looking at whether it can make our
brains work better and longer going long
periods of time sometimes even whole
days with little to no food is a popular
way to boost performance for some
silicon valley types but does it
actually work are there any drawbacks
and how long do you have to go without
eating let's take a look
before we do that it's important to note
that fasting comes with certain risks
and nobody should try it before talking
to their doctor first with that said
let's talk about how long you have to
fast to see any potential benefits the
researchers i talked to said it was a
minimum of 12 to 14 hours that has to do
with how the body fuels itself
usually the body uses glucose as sugar
as fuel but after about 12 hours of
fasting the body starts using ketones
which come from fats the time is shorter
if you exercise scientists think it's
that metabolic switch that starts a
chain of events that leads to some of
the potential brain related benefits of
intermittent fasting so what are the
benefits
neuroscientists like mark matson who
study the effects of intermittent
fasting on animal brains have found that
it can improve focus slow declines in
brain health and improve cells ability
to cope with their version of stress in
people there's some preliminary evidence
that it can help with mood too
[Music]
in his animal research mark looked at
the hippocampus which is a brain region
that's important for learning and memory
he found that during fasting some
neurons in the hippocampus which respond
to glutamate the brain's most important
chemical messenger are more active those
are the brain cells that help you learn
and remember what's important
if you're an animal in the wild you're
hungry you haven't found anything to eat
for a long time
those neural circuits involved in trying
to figure out where to get the food
better be active but then something
really interesting happens in the brains
of his animals after weeks of
intermittent fasting memory becomes more
efficient that happens because a
separate set of neurons quiets down the
activity of some of those glutamate
friendly neurons specifically those that
aren't involved in the task at hand
basically your brain becomes more
efficient by turning down the noise and
focusing in and i've i've noticed this
personally that i really function well
in the morning when i haven't eaten
anything
preliminary evidence from courtney
peterson another intermittent fasting
expert i spoke to suggests that there
could be some mood related benefits we
found that people reported a greater
energy levels fewer feelings of
depression and dejection and individuals
who actually
stuck with the program five days a week
every week they also reported less anger
intermittent fasting may also help slow
down declines in brain health at least
in older patients that's because fasting
kicks into high gear a process called
autophagy which literally means
self-eating autophagy might sound weird
but it might help explain why the
handful of studies that have found brain
related benefits of intermittent fasting
have found the strongest effects among
older people one study in patients with
mild cognitive impairment which usually
precedes alzheimer's found that
intermittent fasting had benefits in
keeping further mental decline at bay so
you might be wondering how are these
things connected less food equals better
brain health well
think of autophagy as the cell's
recycling system it helps keep your
neurons and by extension your brain free
of toxic junk during this process little
pac-man style sacs engulf old proteins
and mitochondria that aren't working
properly and causing your cell stress
those proteins in mitochondria get
chewed up and their components are used
again as we grow older though our cells
become more prone to being filled up
with toxic proteins in part because
autophagy becomes less efficient so
that's where fasting comes into play it
gives autophagy a little boost
this is all really interesting science
but intermittent fasting isn't for
everyone i generally don't recommend it
before you know your mid-20s that's
because it can stunt growth courtney
also said you should avoid it if you're
pregnant if you have diabetes consult
with your doctor and for those who work
the night shift scientists know even
less about its effects on people one of
the drawbacks to intermittent fasting is
that food is social so people feel like
they're missing out on life if they
can't eat with their friends plus fasts
that last whole days may not work as
well long term because people get hungry
or hangry i mean chocolate and cheetos
sound really good right now
moving forward courtney told me that a
big open question was which fasting
schedules actually work and mark is
currently scanning people's brains to
look for changes in brain activity in
connectivity between brain areas in
other words he wants to replicate his
animal studies in people if researchers
are able to pin down the benefits and
drawbacks of intermittent fasting more
specifically then people would be able
to make more informed decisions about
whether to try it or not
[Music]